Oh a country in mourning Thursday's
memorial ceremony began in the Supreme
Leader's residence in Tehran the
commander in chief of Iran's Armed
Forces accompanied by the man who has
replaced the assassinated general
awesome soleimani
as head of the Revolutionary Guards
foots force similar memorial services
were held across the country to mark the
US killing of general Soleimani in
Baghdad on Friday and on Wednesday
this was Iran's promised response this
video was broadcast on state TV it
appears to show members of the
Revolutionary Guard loading ballistic
missiles before launching them into the
night sky their targets a military base
across the border in Iraq housing US
soldiers the man in charge of that
operation is the head of Iran's
Revolutionary Guards aerospace unit
Brigadier General Ali Hodges la-de-da
dream of 8ball the missile attack
conducted against the US military base
was a move that God willing will be
continued Iran was not after killing US
personnel our goal was to hit US
military equipment an immediate
diplomatic solution to the crisis seems
unlikely Iran wants US forces to
permanently leave the Gulf region I
think the revenge for general Soleimani
for Indians is something very strategic
in four-line turn and as a leader
himself also mentioned it is to make the
Americans leave the region and I think
that many nations in the originals who
are supporting these political phases
the US says it's targeting of Qasem
Soleimani in an air strike was in
response to an attack in Iraq in which
an American contractor was killed and
for which it blames Iran but a recent
unclassified memo appears to contradict
Trump's claims that general Soleimani
pose an immediate danger to the United
States
Iranian officials have united in their
response to solely money's death for now
a number of countries are trying to use
all political channels to deescalate
tensions between the United States and
Iran but Solomon EES death is not likely
to open a path of dialogue between the
two longtime adversaries dorsa Jabari al
Jazeera Tehran